[Music]
the previous video got us introduced to
a unique concept of homologous series
that is the concept in which compounds
with the same general formula appear in
succession now in this video let's get
introduced to another interesting
concept what if I tell you that there
are many carbon compounds which possess
the same number of atoms in them but
have completely different structures
what do I mean can there be compounds
that have the same number of atoms of
each element in them but arranged
differently yes this is the concept of
isomers isomers is the term that
originated from the two Greek terms izo
meaning same or equal and miró's meaning
parts does here the term represents the
compounds that have exactly the same
number of atoms of each element in them
however the arrangement of these atoms
is completely different for the sake of
understanding let us assume we have a
compound like this there are two atoms
of a one atom of B and D and three atoms
of C now look at this structure the
number of atoms of each element is the
same but the structure is different
there could be many more combinations
that could rise if we rearrange the
atoms all these structures can be called
as isomers of each other how do we
define isomers then isomers can be
defined as the compounds which have the
same molecular formula but different
structural formula and does different
properties that means if we take
molecules of the isomers and compare
them then the number of atoms in each
molecule will be the same but their
structural or spatial arrangement will
be different wait what do we mean by
structural and spatial arrangement of
atoms we will see that in the next video
[Music]